sebastian lege zeigt euch wie
probiotischer joghurt und leid margarine
billig produziert und sehr teuer
verkauft werden und dabei nicht gerade
gesund sind
[Musik]
[Applaus]
gesundes essen fitness und wohlbefinden
als verkaufsargument probiotisch wirksam
gut fürs immunsystem längst soll essen
nicht mehr nur satt machen soll uns auch
zu einem besseren leben verhelfen
8 hat ist ja auch so eine fitness wolke
ist ja auch etwas schönes war spannend
ist und ich stelle jetzt mal so was für
sie her in super günstig probiotisch
klingt nach wissenschaft und kostet
natürlich extra aber was ist daran
besonders aus milch kann man viel machen
käse zum beispiel etwas laub zu milch
und schon setzt sich der begehrte käse
bruch ab übrig bleibt molke
nährstoffreich aber geschmacklich nicht
jedermanns sache
in rohform unverkäuflich ganz anders als
molke drink mit fruchtgeschmack
[Musik]
meistens haben diese produkte irgendeine
geschmacksrichtung alle frucht varianten
vanille und co heute haben wir gesagt
wir machen maracuja damit wir ein
schönes mundgefühl erhalten ein bisschen
winter guten schuss süßstoff
magermilchpulver minimal fertig ist läge
es maracuja molke drin und der wird
jetzt probiotisch aufgehübscht mit
lebenden milchsäurebakterien
[Musik]
probiotische bakterien kleines tröpfchen
dieser wunder zu trat das reicht schon
zum glück sind die milchsäurebakterien
so harmlos wie preiswert den schnöden
molke drink verwandeln sie in ein
probiotisches getränk dass sich teuer
verkaufen lässt
[Musik]
zum wohl auf ein gesundes leben
[Applaus]
richtig gut
fruchten schön cremig durch den winter
die probiotischen bakterien diesem
schweren grippe
ich würde mal sagen turnschuhe an
ich gehe eine runde joggen
aber bringt der fitness trinkt wirklich
zusätzliche fitness was ist dran an den
wellness und total versprechen mit denen
so viele produkte werben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
schaut man genauer hin sind zweifel
angebracht
selbst wenn ein becher eine milliarde
bakterien enthält und man wohlwollend
annimmt dass ein zehntel davon noch
lebend im darm ankommt sind dass
trotzdem nur 0,0001 prozent dessen was
dort sowieso schon vorhanden ist das ist
so als würde man im berliner grunewald
einen einzigen neuen baum pflanzen gut
gedacht aber ohne großen effekt
ob probiotische joghurts jetzt gesünder
sind als normale joghurts da hat die
wissenschaftlichen letzten spruch noch
nicht gesprochen und die tendenz geht so
es sind joghurts
kein wunder denn auch jeder normaler
naturjoghurt enthält lebende bakterien
probiotische zusätze schaden nicht aber
ob sie es wirklich besser machen
wissenschaftlich jedenfalls ist das
letzte wort noch nicht gesprochen
[Musik]
wir bieten an einen naturjoghurt einen
mit probiotischen bakterien und einen
mit extra vitaminen wofür würden sich
die berliner entscheiden
ich habe meistens naturjoghurt und tut
mir dann eben meine
früchte eben rein oder je nachdem was
ich im rhein haben möchte
jeder soll einen angemessenen
preisausschreiben für naturjoghurt
würden unsere tester im schnitt 70 bis
80 cent pro becher ausgeben
deutlich mehr als er in wirklichkeit
kostet für bakterien draufzahlen nicht
mit den berlinern 70 bis 80 cent genau
wie beim naturjoghurt ist auch schon
großzügig gerechnet
[Musik]
für zusätzliche vitamine sind unsere
testpersonen dagegen durchaus bereit
mehr zu zahlen
der gute ruf der vitamine als gesund
macher zeigt wirkung
[Musik]
werde jetzt mehr werden bei der vitamine
drin sind die mir gut tun
die 12
gleich
vitamine auf einmal und da würde ich
mehr ausgeben keine frage ohne vitamine
können wir nicht überleben
doch nirgends in deutschland herrscht
heute noch vitaminmangel
[Musik]
wer gesund ist und sich einigermaßen
ausgewogen ernährt braucht keine
vitaminzusätze oder pillen
[Musik]
vor allem eltern sollten beim wort
vitamin auf packungen lieber stutzig
werden
unser experte entdeckt beim genauen
hinsehen hinter der gesunden fassade
jede menge süßes kalorienbomben die
genau das gegenteil von ausgewogener
ernährung sind sieht aus wie ein kinder
produkt multivitamin erfrischungsgetränk
12 prozent frucht aus sechs früchte nach
da haben sie aber mal richtig
reingehauen oder und ganz wichtig mit
zusatz von vitaminen a chance ich
begleite echten kinder produkt was aus
wasser und zucker besteht also das sind
so sachen ja kinder wären damit animiert
viel viel zucker zu sich zu nehmen
obwohl für ihn wirklich nicht gut ist
wir wissen uns alle in so einem tütchen
stecken umgerechnet sechs stück
würfelzucker und die vitamine
dann doch lieber einen apfel achtet ihr
aufzusetzen milchprodukten oder hast du
die getrost beiseite sagt es uns in den
kommentaren
aber wie sieht es nun mit light
produkten aus was steckt hier eigentlich
trennen
light produkte längst ein klassiker
denn viele deutsche kämpfen mit
empfunden und hoffen auf einen genuss
ohne reue
die industrie weiß das und bietet so gut
wie alles auch in einer light variante
an die weniger kalorien weniger zucker
oder weniger fett enthält
er lässt alles wölkchen leicht
erscheinen
wer leiht trick
wie man es schafft dem essen die
kalorien auszutreiben wird sebastian
lege jetzt zeigen bei der mutter aller
diätprodukte der light margarine
für unsere leitlinie brauchen auch
folgende zutaten pflanzenöl palmfett
milchpulver monat juli zur rede
vitamin e vitamin d beta carotin vitamin
a und was wäre eine lite margarine ohne
wasser weil davon brauchen wir einiges
palmfett und bindemittel sorgen dafür
dass die margarine schön fest und
streichzart wird vitamine sind gut fürs
image aroma- und farben sollen geschmack
und aussehen von mutter emittieren
[Musik]
dann klettert ihn als emulgator wird das
wasser restlos gebunden so die illusion
ist geglückt das muss jetzt noch ein
paar stunden im kühlschrank und dann kam
uns ganz genüsslich ein brot mit
streichen
bis auf die etwas klein geratene farbe
ist die selbstgemachte leid margarine
kaum von einer normalen zu unterscheiden
[Musik]
für 40 prozent der rest wasser darf ich
stehen ganz gut da probiere war das
ganze mal
klassisch auf der scheibe brot
[Musik]
darauf dankt chemie hat lege den
fettgehalt von 80 auf 40 prozent
geschrumpft aber wie schmeckt die
margarine für die schlanke linie
[Musik]
was mich wirklich komisch nur dass durch
wäre für mich überhaupt gar keine
alternative egal ob zucker oder fett
sobald sie einen faktor um 30 prozent
reduzieren dürfen hersteller ihr produkt
als light bewerten
aber wie viel kalorien spart man damit
wirklich
[Musik]
die zwillinge sandra und diana müller
machen für uns den test einen tag lang
mit sandra nur light produkte essen ihre
schwester ernährt sich ganz normal wie
groß wird die kalorien ersparen es am
ende sein
los geht's mit dem frühstück sandra darf
beim fettarmen joghurt und
zuckerreduzierte müsli nach lust und
laune zulangen
man fühlt sich irgendwie schon zum
bisserl besser einfach ich denke okay
jetzt dass ich kann jetzt ein müsli
essen mit joghurt allem drum und dran
und aber trotzdem tue ich mir was gutes
liegt sie nach dem fettarmen joghurt und
leid müsli wirklich vorn
pro 100 gramm gerechnet ist der
unterschied bei müsli praktisch 0 406
kilokalorien im vergleich zu 3 198 beim
leitprodukt einschließlich hält am
joghurt sparte portion müsli immerhin 76
kilokalorien
[Musik]
beim mittagessen bringt das
fertiggericht von weight watchers mit
360 kalorien zwar einen deutlichen
vorteil im vergleich zum standard
gericht mit 523 beim salat dressing aber
schnapp dann die erste leid falle zu
sandra greift zum joghurtdressing
anstatt zum klassiker aus essig und öl
dabei hat er nur 84 kalorien und das
vermeintlich leichte joghurtdressing 327
und damit viermal so viel
[Musik]
damit schrumpft der light vorteil auf
gerade mal 20 kalorien zusammen
beim nachtisch sandras welchen pudding
nur deshalb weniger kalorien weil ihre
portion kleiner ist diana schoko des er
hat über 200 kalorien aber auch 200
gramm der light pudding 116 kalorien bei
125 gramm
wer deshalb noch einen zweiten becher
ist der ist in die nächste leid falle
getappt
beim abendbrot spart sandra durch leid
margarine und käse gegenüber dianas 444
kalorien wieder einiges 1 370 das gibt
einen buchstäblich leichten vorteil bei
chips droht die dritte leidvollen fed
wird durch andere nährstoffe erweckt die
fast ebenso viele kalorien haben
die tagesbilanz fällt ernüchternd aus
nur 147 kalorien nicht mal zehn prozent
hat sandra matt light produkten gespart
dann kann ich eigentlich komplett nach
meinem geschmack gehen was wir wirklich
besser tut oder gefällt und frau merkt
eigentlich keine sorgen machen über leid
oder nicht leid
fazit wer abnehmen will sollte das nicht
nur durch light-produkte versuchen
weniger fett oder zucker bedeutet
nämlich nicht automatisch auch weniger
kalorien
[Musik]
versucht ihr zucker oder fett zu
reduzieren welche tricks habt ihr da auf
lager teilt es mit uns in den
kommentaren
und wo ist die besten lebensmittel gibt
und was wirklich drin steckt zeigen wir
euch auf unserem kanal zdf besser esser